well thank you all for
thanks for your interest in this
in this topic maybe Brian didn't notice
justysia and here are the virtues I
think that's magnanimity and so on from
the very painting by Lorenzetti which
was is on the Town Hall of the wall of
ilk emunah in in Siena we didn't plan
this by the way and here at the same
time this this was just a decade or so
before this painting was done a
statement from the constitution of Siena
the city must be governed by men who
love peace and justice so probably I
soaked up part of that tradition having
been lecturing there for the past thirty
years and having gotten quite interested
in early modern political thought partly
as a result of that now because I have
these very critical respondents coming
up actually I should tell you how this
happened I got a very critical email
from one of them and I thought it was so
interesting that I thought gosh let's
just talk about that you can guess which
one it was it's a probably I hope it'll
be the most critical of the four because
was actually was pretty critical so I
decided I'd better clean up my act and
sort of defend myself in advance well
the first thing is the poster that
you've all seen which is very beautiful
that's not Florence that's obviously a
Canaletto and it's painting and by
canaletto and it's obviously st. Mark's
I've got the same article in in Venice
it's not even Siena but then there's
another problem what about the title
this this has also been criticized in
other emails I mean it's a knockoff
title I mean for example it just is Adam
Adams fallacy I mean I'm borrowing it
obviously from my dear friend a very
good economists Duncan Foley or what
about des cartes error I mean it's been
taken already
or you know with their other other books
you know which have similar sounding
titles so I I'll have to correct all of
these things the paintings in title and
everything in in previous episodes
there's been a lot that we talked about
beginning with the quote which you see
before you from the discourses of
Machiavelli departing from what's called
the Aristotelian tradition I gave you
some evidence from
Accra Ghana that actually it may be true
that market like incentives may drive
out religion and make people less
generous as a result I talked about
Humes idea that constitutions should be
designed as if individuals were knaves I
talked a little bit about the evidence
about cooperativeness and incentives the
Boston firemen who all called in sick
when the Commissioner imposed incentives
to prevent them from calling in sick and
he docked their pay this is a guy who is
a fisherman in Brazil in the public
goods game the ones who played very
cooperatively in the public goods game
also turn out to be very green minded
fishers and they used nets with very
small mesh as very large mesh so as to
let the little fish out and so on I
mentioned Adam Smith will come back to
some of his ideas as well now the the
idea of Machiavelli's mistake is this
that the the the idea to which which I
say is mistaken and which is only with
some stretching attributed to anything
like Machiavelli but rather to a
tradition which I think he had a hand in
starting was this material incentives
can implement socially desirable
outcomes irrespective of individual
preferences so civic virtue may be
dispensed with almost entirely almost is
because of the proviso about well who's
designing these incentives after all
they cannot be exempted from the
requirement of virtue the I've argued
that it's mistaken first this is the
subject for the first lecture because
these incentives on which the dominant
paradigm is based depend may crowd out
the social preferences I call it the the
idea of this non crowding out the
crowding out would not occur that the
social preferences and and
self-interested preferences or material
preferences could be additive I called
the supper ability assumption and I
showed lots of evidence from experiments
and also from real life that that
probably fails
now here I want to say we I want to
return to the topic of the why it is
that social preferences are
essential and the fundamental reasoning
is that the contracts which regulate our
activities in many areas there aren't
even contracts but even where we have
the contracts the contracts are
incomplete like they're either non
enforceable or they don't cover
everything that we care about and
sometimes in the presence of incomplete
contracts we try to design mechanisms is
what it's called in economics that is
incentive systems which will implement
these outcomes which are desirable and I
want to convince you that these are
insufficient to ensure a good solution
to the kinds of problems which we face
one of the reasons for that which I
won't develop here but which I think is
an interesting idea which I would like
to develop a bit is that mechanism
design as it's been as it's been
developed is actually a very poor idea
in a very liberal society and the reason
is if you read carefully the fine print
of these highly mathematical papers they
rely heavily on very large penalties and
on acquiring information most of the
ways of acquiring information there one
or two exceptions to this would violate
ordinary notions of privacy the very
large penalties we used to call them
debtors prisons or whipping slaves or
perhaps in inflicting physical harm on
people for economic malfeasance it's no
longer acceptable to do that thankfully
but it does suggest that many of these
incentive systems which are said to be
part of giving the invisible hand a
helping hand would it be absolutely
anathema in a liberal society if they
were taken seriously now these are the
reasons why I think this view at the top
is mistaken in this in the second
lecture I raised the obvious question
which is well if this top thing is true
if the crowding out phenomenon is true
it could very well be that the
institutions that they're liberals
advocate are self-destructive in the
sense that dynamically unstable because
they don't reproduce the values upon
which their functioning depends and I
showed that that is probably not true in
this lecture that I want to ask what the
sophisticated legislate
should do this the the sophisticated
legislator is the one who knows this
stuff believes it and thinks it's true
knows all these experiments and now has
to design incentives that don't have
these counterproductive effects which
I've talked about the examples being the
Boston firemen and so on so I'll be
talking about the two things in the
boxes here now why is it important that
we do this I just actually wrote this
slide this morning because I wanted to I
wanted to tell you why why I'm doing
this why am I writing this book and well
I should say I've been I've been working
on it for 20 years did I tell you that
in the first lecture of my first paper
on this topic of this was written in
1988 I presented it in the philosophy
department of the University College
London in 1989 I thought it was a good
idea but I thought it was a pretty weak
paper and so I sat on it for almost 20
years
until I actually had a little more
information on the topic this has been a
very abiding topic with me and the
reason is this I'm having second
thoughts about whether prices can do the
job of morals which is this is the
thought this is Mandeville here by the
way where he said human frailties maybe
turned to the advantage of civil society
and made to supply the place of moral
virtue that's the topic which I that's
the that that's the assertion which I
find extremely dubious given the kinds
of problems which we face today
okay real world economics we're this is
no longer an economy of grain and steel
forget the covers of economics textbooks
which have smokestacks and fields of
grain that's not what's going on anymore
in the economy where an economy which is
based on the production of knowledge
information distribution of that but
also we're living in a world in which
our well-being depends importantly on
such things as infection political
violence global warming and so on these
are things which are quintessentially
those aspects of social interactions
that can never be enforced in a complete
contract
so I I want to convince you or at least
I want to tell you what I think about
this that we're moving into an economy
in which whatever it was said about the
invisible hand and the possibility of
having more complete contracts and
that's solving our problem in the
economy of grain and steel it's unlikely
to be true in the economy of the future
what is called perhaps indicating its
difficulty of its intangible nature the
weightless economy it's unlikely to work
for that and that being the case we're
going to have to rely on people's moral
orientations or social preferences to a
considerably greater extent in the
future than in the past
and I the way I remember this it's an
economy of handshakes not of Peace rates
in economics as you may know we treat
the product that we treat working as if
it was a matter of peace traits we don't
even ask why people work as hard as they
do or not we act as if they're paid by
the number of shirts they produce in
many textbooks well you know peace rates
are probably about now something like
three percent of the labor force worked
for peace rates in American economy it's
just that kind of ability to measure
what's going on is not what's a part of
the economy today now Adam Smith said
the self-interest of the butcher and the
Baker would put the dinner on the table
and I believe that and I believe that
well-defined property rights and
competition on markets will accomplish
that for the things that are going to be
put on the table however I don't believe
that the problems I mentioned above can
be handled in the same way and I think
they will require a decent amount of
combination of incentives and what I'll
call in an anachronistic way Civic
virtues to solve the problem now many of
you know about some of you may have read
this book the gift relationship from
human blood to social policy was written
in 1971 and in it chitinous said that if
you pay for blood essentially you don't
get a good blood donation program he's
contrasting America in England
interestingly too
the most famous economists in the world
can arrow and Bob Solow wrote reviews of
that book long reviews they took it very
seriously but at the end of the day they
said they didn't think it was true and
there was some reason to doubt that it
was true
first there was little evidence that the
social prep what I call social
preferences these other regarding or
ethical preferences were at all common I
mean obviously sociologists and
anthropologists thought they were an
economists and biologists knew that they
weren't and that's about where the
matter stood until we got a very large
number of experiments suggesting that in
fact in most subject pools around the
world those preferences are in fact very
common now there was even less evidence
that the use of these incentives would
actually crowd out these social
preferences were they to exist in fact
there was very little at all and they
certainly was very little in the book by
tipis and finally in 1961 a 71 we were
pretty confident that was was then
called the new welfare economics and
came to be called mechanism design and
so on we're quite confident that we
could design these mechanisms where to
implement a socially desirable efficient
outcome for the economy on the basis of
these clever incentives where the market
failed now that's all changed mechanism
design has grown tremendously and we
found its limits we know a lot more
about human preferences now another
thing happened more recently what is
called to those of you who studied macro
economics it's called the Lucas critique
and lucas raised a very obvious question
he said look when we design
macroeconomic policies we trust that
individuals in the society have certain
beliefs about what's going to happen and
then we introduce a policy
taking account of those beliefs but what
happens if the policies affect the
beliefs he was talking about
unemployment and inflation this
immediately rocked the policy-making
establishment and economics because it
was so obviously truth the policy alters
what people think you've got to make the
beliefs and dodging asst when you design
a policy so what I'm suggesting here is
exactly similar to the Lucas critique
those of you from economic
it's a it's an idea in which we should
make the preferences endogenous we
should look at the effect of the policy
on the preferences and then study the
outcome well the key to studying that
outcome must be some kind of equilibrium
notice with Lucas the beliefs were taken
to be dynamic they depended on the
policies I want to urge you to think
about the the Preferences as being
similarly dynamic so that there's some
kind of equilibrium between the policy
interventions and the preferences
whereby the Preferences will be
technically stationary that is you take
a kind of where they'll move in response
to the tax rate or the fine or the fee
and so on okay so here's where this
sophisticated planner might start is
reading after I published the paper
surveying this Tom shaoling wrote me
this email can you read it maybe not ah
yeah particularly she can have one of
those spots on me so you know you know
so okay wait if you turn the lights down
for this slide after all okay so this is
um this I I'll just read it this is
shelling for in the white house in the
early 50s those were exciting and
stimulating times people worked long
hours and felt compensated by the sense
of accomplishment and I believe a sense
of personal importance regularly a
Friday afternoon meeting would go on
until 8 or 9 when the chairman would
suggest resuming Saturday morning
nobody demurred we all knew it was
important and we were important sometime
in 52 I believe it was President Truman
issued the order that anyone who worked
on Saturday was to receive overtime pay
what happened Saturday meetings
virtually disappeared could you turn the
lights back up I this is a little too
mysterious for me thank you
he thought that the this crowding out
non-separable 'ti phenomena was what was
going on there or here's here's David
Packard talking about the founding of
Hewlett Packard and what he learned from
his bad days at General Electric General
Electric was making a big thing of plant
security guarding its tool in parts bins
to make sure employees didn't steal
employees set out to prove this obvious
display of distrust justified walking
off with tools and parts when HP got
underway I determined that our parts
bins
ROS be open and so on is important in
two ways easy access to the parts was it
helped product designers and others who
want to take to work on out new ideas at
home and on weekends and open bins and
storms were a symbol of trust to trust
as a central way to how HP does its
business now notice this is interesting
because these individuals were working
at home they were doing extra work and
the sign of distrust would not only make
it impossible for them to work it all
would presumably make them a little less
interested in this or consider the
following I love this one okay there's
this tax collector somewhere in Andhra
Pradesh in India and he's having a hard
time getting the taxes collected so what
does he do he hires ten drummers to go
out and beat their drums outside the
houses of the people who are not paying
their taxes and they pay up like crazy
and his idea is of course that they're
ashamed everyone knows when the
drummer's show up at your house that
you're a deadbeat taxpayer and of course
this reminded me of char Eve Ari's in
early modern Europe it may have predated
that but in many countries of Europe a
miscreant either a womanizing husband or
a price gouging Baker or some some
Grandy who was exploiting his noble
titles and so on would be greeted by a
large group of people coming to his home
they were mostly women usually beating
pots and pans and generally drawing
attention to his low moral character all
right so these contrasts tell us
something about the range of
interventions that you might think about
okay the the sophisticated legislator
first has to think about this problem
how do I design institution so that
incentives are synergistic with ethical
and other regarding preferences that is
how do we make them so they crowd in
their compliments rather than crowding
out their substitutes then having done
that we have to think about what's the
optimal level of the incentive that of
the tax or fee or whatever it is if
you're going to use one at all now by
the way this optimal incentive argument
is a big literature in economics optimum
it's called optimal taxation it's in the
old days now the first task how do you
design institutions so that incentives
have
complementary synergistic effects is it
immediately runs into a problem and
that's that situations which look very
similar fines or incentives seem to have
opposite effects now I think the way to
understanding what's going on I'll give
you some of these puzzle in just a
minute but Hayek revolutionized the way
economists think about markets when he
said prices have two functions they both
send some information and they provide a
motivation for doing something so
there's the message and the motivation
if you like alliteration which obviously
I do the so just think about the price
as conveying information now with Hayek
of course it was conveying information
about how scarce the good really was and
that was his information theoretic
revision of market theory which actually
it was a very good idea now I want to
suggest that things like prices have the
same message function if you find
somebody it may be just a price step
right up and buy it it could be a signal
something about the intent of the guy
who imposed the price it could be an
insult and it could also be a teacher
okay I'm stretching it with the teacher
but you'll see what I mean the prices
the prices can structure your world in
such a way that you learn things you
wouldn't otherwise learn so this is a
case in which a fine is just a price
those of you who know the literature
must wonder how I've gone three lectures
it's and this is the first time I've
introduced this particular example
because it's such a great experiment in
some - a care centers parents are coming
late to pick up their kids and at the
beginning of at some particular time a
fine was imposed no explanation was
given a little thing when outside the
door says said as from Monday parents
coming more than 10 minutes late will
have to pay 10 NIS to shekels to the to
the school there are two sets there was
a control group and there was a there's
a group with define this that's the
group of the fine that's a control group
they're pretty similar here then you
impose the fine here in week six and the
group which has to find doubles the
amount of lateness
that's not the only thing you'll notice
about it I mean it's an extraordinary
big effect lateness doubled
we'll come back to this I mean not
surprisingly after week 17 they forgot
it there's but they'll forget to find
and things didn't go back to the status
quo ante that's a hint about something
which I'll bring up much later well that
was just a price what about adjust price
well in Ireland a tax was passed on
garbage bags it was a very small sum 20
cents in u.s. dollars at the time and it
was preceded by weeks of a media
campaign about how nasty garbage bags
were in the gorgeous Irish countryside
and urban landscape and within two weeks
after the imposition of the tax the use
of the bags had disappeared
virtually disappeared amazing and the
most obvious interpretation that people
will give you is that somehow we don't
know how carrying a plastic gar
grocery bag home from from the store got
to be a little bit like wearing a
genuine fur coat people were likely to
come up to you and say well hey what
about that grocery bag now we obviously
have to understand why - and Ireland
were so different what was going on
whereby in both cases a relatively
modest incentive had such different
effects well I get inspiration from this
will surprise you seeing I was talking
about Benson's duty and interest
principle that is incentive alignment
for the public servant in my first
lecture here's what he said about
punishments a punishment should be a
moral lesson when by reason of the
ignominy it stamps on the offence it is
calculated to inspire the public with
sentiments of aversion towards those
pernicious habits and dispositions with
which the offence appears to be
connected and thereby to inculcate the
opposite beneficial habits and
dispositions I think this is exactly
right notice this is the message idea
now the does this tell us about why -
and Ireland were different I don't know
it'd be fantastic to try to really study
that but I think very important was the
the the
the publicity propaganda prior to the
tax in Ireland probably had a big impact
and secondly if you come late to pick up
your kid the only person there is the
teacher most likely because it was quite
rare people were coming late and when
you're shopping you're shopping in
public if you come late to the daycare
it's always possible it was traffic no
particular decision you made perhaps you
were careless but you didn't exactly
make a choice to be late you are making
a choice on a plastic bag so there are
all kinds of things that if you think
about the processing if people would go
through that in one case they might have
acted very positively and the other
negatively a fine in addition to being a
message can also be an insult the you
remember the trust game there's an inn
there's an investor and he or she
transfers a sum of money to the trustee
the amount is then doubled by the
experimenter and the trustee can
transfer back some money to the investor
in both cases you can do nothing you can
the first guy can send nothing or if the
second guy gets something he can he can
send nothing back now the the trustee
that sorry the investor investor
attempts to control the amount return
backfired very strongly and this is a
graph which I showed you these people
here the controlling the guys said okay
I could you have to send back at least
10
well the these people were all people
who'd sent back zero without the control
and then they sent back ten when it was
required all these these people
apparently had been voluntarily giving
ten and they also gave ten once it was
required
all of these people reduced the amount
that they give gave after the imposition
of the fine here's another example from
in it from a similar game that I think
will allow us to extract another
possible reason for this that just said
insult it's obvious that the people who
were but the people are asked about what
do you think about this controlling your
behavior and people said it's a sign of
distrust but this is a game same game
but I think we get a different different
answer from it think about how Homo
economicus would play this game it's the
same game as like one I just described
well it
find the investor I might guess what
kind of person you were
but if I guess that you also were Homo
economicus it's clear what I would do
I'd give nothing because if you were
home working on because you'd give
nothing back so that's the way the game
should be played what happens in fact is
that if you give a lot you got a lot
back there's a lot of reciprocity in
this game and here's this is some
examples of this when there's no fine
possible those are the gray bars when
the fine is possible and it's not used
those are the white bars and the black
bars are when the fine is used let me
explain the white bars they had the the
so I'm the investor and at brian is the
trustee or the respondent and he knows
that I could find him if he didn't give
stuff back i renounced the fine I
actually have to make a choice he knows
I made that choice and then I give him
you know seven dollars or something
now this is how much the investor
transferred and that's the back transfer
the vertical height of the bars is a
measure of reciprocity or rather the
slope of this the response to larger
amount is the measure of reciprocity
it's obvious that the fine backfired in
the sense that you got less reciprocity
and in the case of the fine but what's
really obvious is that have being able
to do the fine and not doing it was the
best of all that's the white bars right
so what does that tell us well that
tells us that the use of the fine was
saying something about the character of
the individual and being able to find
but not using it was a clear message
that I'm an okay kind of God now let's
see if we can milk that particular case
for a little bit more juice oh can you
milk something for juice milk for
something sustenance squeeze it for more
juice sorry about that okay
I'm gonna think about this it's probable
I think that incentives per se are not
the culprit here there's something else
going on here's why I think that do you
remember this game this is a public
goods with punishment game you remember
how that's played it's just a 10-person
prisoner's dilemma in which after each
contribution people can punish those
that we would never use such a word who
had contributed lo this is what happens
when there is punishing going on people
contribute a lot people punish a lot and
people respond very positively to the
punishment take away the punishment and
down it goes it unravels here's the case
it just gave you what's the puzzle well
in both cases they're fines being
imposed in one case the fine works like
a dream
people respond very positively and we
know econometric aliy the experiments
I've done with this game you have a huge
response to getting fine in the previous
round a lot of learning goes on why is
that game different from that game well
let's think about it in the first case
that is in the public goods game
particularly in the stranger treatment
you know that's when you will not be
playing with the same people next round
if I punish you
for a low contribution I can't possibly
benefit I'm just being civic minded or
maybe I'm you know a lot of
possibilities but the most obvious one
is I'm punishing you because I think you
violated some norm I'm not going to
benefit whoever plays with you next will
benefit but not me in the trust game the
incentive was being posed by a principal
who stood to benefit if the incentive
worked in other words it was a profit
maximizing situation I was so interested
in whether or not that really was the
case I was able to actually look at the
kinds of responses that people got
depending on how much they asked back or
otherwise that get fined they are the
results here if you if you suppose you
divide the investors into two groups
some people said here's $10 and I want
you to give me back whatever number it
is so that I would get all the surplus
or almost all of it and some other
people said here's $10 I want you to
give me back at least this amount which
you keep it back we'll split the surplus
equally so there were two kinds of
investors obviously the fair ones and
the unfair ones in the minds of the
respondents I guess and all of the
crowding out was in the first case this
might this eight percent of crowding out
was not statistically significant from
different from zero so that's a little
clue it says it basically what's going
on here is not that the incentives are
crowding out incentives when they signal
greed on the part of the trustee of
truster sorry investor are the problem
finds are also teachers I mentioned this
thing here why did the behavior persist
after the incentive was withdrawn well
I'm the most obvious answer is that you
learned something in the game that you
didn't forget when the game was over and
as I learn something I mean generically
that like we learned preferences so in
other words the I think the answer to
this is why do we have this it may be
that we have endogenous preferences okay
what's the difference between Framing
and endogenous preferences remember on
the first lecture I said some
preferences or situation dependent in
the sense that they're subject to
queuing framing and so on endogenous
preferences are different in the sense
that if your preferences are endogenous
you learn a new set of preferences and
then you continue with them for some
period of time I'll exaggerate by saying
they are irreversible
whereas situation dependent preferences
are such that if you take away the frame
you go back to your behavior prior to
that now there's lots of experimental
evidence like this the behavior persists
after the incentives go away I don't
think that's really super find evidence
for endogenous preferences because
people adopt their preferences over a
long period of time through
socialization very often our experiences
as adolescents is very important the
likelihood that we would actually
observe endogenous preferences in an
experimental situation is pretty remote
I think but there there are certainly
lots that look like this now we find
other things that are a little more like
it
for example bike messengers around the
world are paid in different kinds of
contracts some are paid by summer
actually formed in cooperatives and some
are paid by normal kind of peace rate
like contracts well it turns out that
the preferences of people in these jobs
are very very different now you may
think they probably select into those
jobs or that's probably not true because
the localities in which this test was
done if you're going to be a bike
messenger
you you have no choice you can't choose
the coop as opposed to the capitalist
bike messenger firm and the form of the
contract had a huge was very strongly
covary
with the degree of cooperativeness in
ultimatum games in public goods games or
what about Mechanical Turk in the
trolley I'm sure you want to know what
that's about okay well you go on
Mechanical Turk and you do a job well
somebody designed a compensation scheme
on make of Mechanical Turk these were
sort of proofreading type jobs on
Mechanical Turk and their two contracts
one contract was you get paid basically
in proportion to how much you do and the
second one is a winner-take-all contract
like what's called a tournament in
economics and these people didn't even
know they're in an experiment obviously
they were just they got on there and
they they had these terms they should
have said fine and they also then were
given the trolley case probably like the
prisoner's dilemma game is something I
don't have to explain there's a trial
that coming down the track and if you
push somebody off in front of the
trolley you can save five lives of
course you took one life and then the
question is it as you as you get farther
and farther from the tactile act of
pushing somebody to a switch and so on
you're still going to save five people
at the cost of one people make different
decisions it's a very standard problem
in philosophy and actually sees now also
by neuroscientists who try to get at
what's going on and when we make these
either consequentialist or the
ontological decisions about actions well
it turns out that which contract you
worked under had a very big impact on
how you decided whether you push the guy
off or not or whether you'd pull the
switch and so on now why is that I have
no idea and I can assure you the author
of this paper doesn't either it's not me
by the way it's a very nice paper and I
don't think he's in the room but it's a
fantastic demonstration that the task
performance the kind of activities you
do may have an effect on on some message
that you get in an apparently unrelated
area like pushing somebody in front of a
trolley I'm going to pass by this but I
think better evidence for endogenous
preferences is this look at cultures
around the world that are
very distinct in how they make their
living the kinds of economic structures
they live under and ask how they play
differently here we have these are whale
hunters those are the lemma Lyra up
there these are well these are herders
that's the Ormeau right there I'll come
back to them in a minute these are these
Amazonian horticulturalists this is the
payoffs to cooperation as we measured in
their ecology how valuable would it be
to be able to cooperate obviously a lot
in hunting a whale and not that much if
you're slash-and-burn horticulturalist
in the Amazon here we have the offers in
the ultimatum game a measure either of
generosity or a belief in the
fair-mindedness of the respondent or
some combination to both rather strong
positive relationship here extremely
robust by the way I tried to make that
relationship go away econometric lee and
it won't go away it's it's definitely
there it's a normalized regression
coefficient of about 0.6 so that's a
large number so what it suggests is how
people make their living makes a big
difference in how they cooperate of
course I would like to air drop some of
the lemma Lara into the Amazon and see
how they turn out after a couple of
generation but so far I haven't been
able to get approval for that there are
many other studies which come to the
same conclusion some of them are
empirically extremely persuasive and
early paper by Bacon at all on economic
structure and child-rearing you'll see
the quote knowledge of an economy alone
would enable the one to predict with
considerable accuracy whether a society
socialization pressures were primarily
towards compliance or towards assertion
another one almost exactly the same
subject child-rearing values in modern
industrial societies you want to predict
them ok you can all take guesses about
what's going to predict them religion
education income whatever you want
another thing you should have said you
should have said whether you give orders
on the job or whether you take orders on
the job it's a very powerful predictor
of whether you want your kid to be
independent or obedient and finally big
differences between pastoralists and
farmers these are East African ones in
the value of Independence based on the
way they make their living and I mention
this one because everybody at some
points in
now wait a second are you sure that
people aren't selecting into these jobs
and that's where you're getting your
correlation from well this one by
Edgerton very nicely did a correlation
not only between whether you're a
pastoralists or agriculturalists
and your values he said forget what you
are let's just look if you live in a
place where you couldn't be a pastor
list or an agriculturist that is he used
an instrumental variable as we call it
in economics based on the geography to
predict the same thing and remarkably
the correlations were only marginally
reduced so this is a very powerful
finding which deals with that
endogeneity problem now how can we
understand what's going on I've bet I'm
telling stories right I want to convince
you that this is really happening that
economies produce goods and services and
they also produce people and therefore
how you use incentives in an economy is
going to be important part of what
people turn out what can what what can
we do about this in terms of actually
modeling well there are models of
cultural evolution Boyd and Richardson
pioneered this field and there are now a
lot of models including some by
economists the basic idea is this an
economy determines who you meet to do
what with what rewards that effects
essentially which kinds of people are
going to be doing well if you model that
you find out not surprisingly that when
you have institutions that reward
self-interest highly or that give little
reward or scope for other rewarding
preferences which make it hard to do
that that will contribute to the
proliferation of selfish traits as long
as the cultural copying is what it's
called is responsive to payoffs or
responsive to the distribution of types
in the popula in your experience now so
I I think the the the idea here is that
if you organize a society along certain
lines you're likely to have cultural
consequences of the type that I've
mentioned in the in the in saying why I
thought that Adam Smith's argument for
the beneficial effects of trading on the
behavior of merchants might not be
adequate
I made the argument that Smiths are
gifts case for why the for the probity
of the merchant was based on the idea
that you have a very primitive kind of
market in which people have endless
contact with the same individuals you
don't have a modern market where you
have as what I called anonymity and
ephemeral contact if you did his model
wouldn't work and neither would any of
the game theoretic models about why we
get cooperation among selfish
individuals because of repeated games
that all requires that this game be
ongoing and other things like the
reputation arguments would would give
you the same consequence so to summarize
very briefly because I want to move on
to the discussion portion of the flight
the the argument here is if you made
markets work the way the textbooks in
economics say they ought to work you
would destroy their capacity to produce
the cultural attributes that make
markets possible got it that's that
that's the one-liner all right now by
the way I don't know if that's true but
that's the argument that's what I'm
trying to say the there's a famous thing
in economics called the second best
theorem half a century ago and it's a
remarkable idea it says suppose you're
in an economy in which there's there
some if there are some conditions for
efficient allocation of resources and
suppose a couple of them three or four
are violated for example suppose in some
industry price is not equal to marginal
cost and suppose in some other industry
there is an environmental pollution
correcting one of those may make things
worse rather than better that's all it
is that's all the argument that's the
theorem that is fixing one violation of
an efficiency condition doesn't mean you
move in the right direction now I have a
second second best theorem it goes like
this where contracts are incomplete and
hence norms may be important in
attenuating market failures public
policies and legal practices that more
closely approximate the idealized
complete contracting markets may
exacerbate the underlying market failure
by undermining socially valuable norms
such as trust and reciprocity and may
result in a less if
equilibrium allocation in other words
getting a little closer to the goal
isn't necessarily a good idea and I
think I've given you some evidence it
may actually be a pretty bad idea
well what about incentives it's easy to
misunderstand what I'm saying to think
that I think incentives are bad not at
all
they work very well for lots of jobs
which people would not like to do and in
which the incentive can be not designed
in such a way as to avoid conveying that
bad information about the principle
these are some puzzles that I would like
you to have in your minds I would like
to hear more from you if you have
research ideas in these areas but here's
what I think now framing is what
accounts for the fact that mechanisms
appealing to self-interest often
implement exactly the Nash equilibrium
that is they do exactly what the
economist says as if people were selfish
but in the absence of that incentive
people don't act as if they're selfish I
think framing is a good explanation for
that I don't know if it's I mean now
it's also the case because of endogenous
beliefs and preferences that the
apparent adverse effects of incentives
may sometimes persist for over long
periods of time because of information
about intent
remember the trust game and so on the
its it sometimes is the case that finds
work positively sometimes they work
negatively and here's an interesting
question why are these counterproductive
incentives so widely used they've got to
be good for something
they're good for profits remember in the
in the trust game the ones who are
taking back a large part of the surplus
we're doing very well but so and in many
of these experiments what's done by the
experimenter usually is it tells you
what happened to the social surplus that
is the winnings of both parties with
both sides they almost always go down
that's what it's meant by
counterproductive but often the
incentive can shift the pie to the
principal and away from the agent okay
well here's what we're now turning to
the question of
what would be the optimal amount of the
incentive and I won't go on much about
this obviously more Ireland less Haifa
we've got to design these institutions
so that they're complements rather than
substitutes and we we have to now
determine what the optimal level is and
here's a surprise if you have crowding
out you may want to use incentives more
rather than less
that surprised me in fact I thought I'd
made a mistake
there's a theorem in one of my papers
about this I just couldn't believe that
I was pretty dumb when I finally
realized how the theorem worked of
course it's true that crowding out can
sometimes then induce the sophisticated
legislator not to use the incentives or
to use fewer of them but it's also true
that in many situations the opposite
holds so didymus thought that we
shouldn't use incentives because they
are they they effect crowding out that's
sometimes true but it's not always true
you can think of lots of cases in which
it wouldn't be true we're crowding out
is categorical so that for example the
very presence of an incentive turns you
off but then if you crank it up high
enough you respond to it well you can
see then that that might be a situation
in which you might have to use more
incentives rather than fewer or think
about this case you got a target
compliance problem at least eighty
percent of the population has to get
first aid training and the sophisticated
legislator tells you that oh by the way
the incentive you're going to use
doesn't work very well are you going to
use more of it or less of it well if
you're going to use it at all you'll use
more of it you might decide to abandon
the target but aside from that the this
is almost penultimate I want to say
something about economics in economics
preferences are a summary of what people
do they say nothing about motives that's
a big innovation of the last half
century in economics action is
acquisitive we get stuff
I think both of these are mistaken we
have to understand that I say we are now
for the first time in this lecture
speaking as an economist we have to we
have to understand motives other
disciplines understand this they talk
about the reasons why people do things
for I mean this may be a
misunderstanding for those
of you who are you know sort of just
consumers of economics on the side
preferences are not a reason why
somebody does something it's just a
consistent description of what that
person will do under some conditions I
think we need to go back to the
old-fashioned classical notion of
preferences at reasons why we do things
motives and then start to explore what
those motives might be when we do that
we're gonna have to contrast two modes
of thinking about action one is getting
and the others being the conventional
economic approach is we do stuff in
order to get stuff now buy stuff by the
way I don't mean anything stupid like it
has to be material we try to minimize
the disutility of our effort we care
about time preference and so on but
we're acquiring basically as opposed to
the constitutive aspect of behavior in
which we're trying to be someone either
in our own eyes or in the eyes of others
I think and this is just a speculation
that this particular you may think
rather speculative and ill-thought-out
idea acquisitive constitutive may be the
right road to go down in trying to
understand why we get these surprises
and these unintended effects by way of
summary I think what we found here in
the three lectures is that individuals
are heterogeneous so I'm selfish some
not very many different kinds of types
of behaviors versatile very responsive
to situations able to act one way or
another and plastic change under the
influence of changing social
circumstances incentives are messages as
well as motivation because we have
multiple beliefs about others I mean we
have multiple leads that may be
self-fulfilling remember in the trust
game the ones who are distrusting they
put the limit on how much you could give
and of course those people acted
selfishly so I said that self-fulfilling
but also the ones who didn't act though
in that way also had their beliefs
fulfilled we're in most policy
situations were facing a possibility of
multiple equilibria and so the job of
the sophisticated legislature is not
simply to inch some equilibrium in the
right direction a little greener or
something but actually
choose among psych will there be it's
called equilibrium selection in
economics there are lots of examples of
this but I think it would take too long
to I mean there are lots of little
examples I can give you from experiments
in which the small change in design
changes you from one equilibrium for the
other not invasive it wouldn't violate
any principles it just as a way of
moving from one possible outcome which
is self-sustaining to another and so
back to Aristotle or a constitution for
knaves or both or neither here's here's
my Humes knave statement updated a
little bit not as nice as the way humor
wrote it the task of the policymakers to
devise rules so that in cases where
cooperation is socially desirable other
regarding preferences will be
sustainable in a cultural equilibrium
and individuals with other regarding
preferences will have opportunities to
express their pro-sociality in ways that
induce all or most to cooperate as in
the public goods with punishment
experiments notice we're looking at
heterogeneous populations here in the
case where the thing went collapsing
like that probably a small number of
selfish individuals were driving that
they started contributing little and
everybody else got angry at them just
the same when they sustained the
cooperation it could have been a small
number of civic minded people who are
punishing others so for all we know
looking in that data I haven't looked
carefully at it but just looking at the
growth data it's pretty obvious that it
could be that a small number of civic
minded people sustained a very
cooperative equilibrium or a small
number of selfish people drove that
population to a rather unpleasant
equilibrium this of course raises lots
of interesting questions liberal
neutrality is of course something which
is much debated what it means but in of
the kinds of intervention in the point
in the formation of values that I think
would be valuable to undertake in a
society would probably violate some
notions of liberal neutrality now by the
way I'm not suggesting that we should
engage in something which we are not now
engaging if what I've said is correct
it's not the case that governments and
other organizations are now refraining
from intervening in your preference
formation and your values they do it all
the time
I'm only advocating it's something which
a democratic society should talk about
rather than having essentially hidden by
the assumptions of economics and other
areas thank you very much